we worried that this would happen and
it's happening covid anti-vaccine
sentiment is now bleeding over into
other vaccines and parents are
increasingly hesitant to get their kids
vaccinated against all sorts of other
things including measles and one of
those uh and and the one of the problems
with that is we are now starting to see
outbreaks exactly as predicted you might
remember back in November we talked
about uh this story CNN reported as
measles outbreak sickens more than a
dozen children in Ohio local Health
officials seek help from the CDC a
growing measles outbreak in Columbus has
sickened more than a dozen unvaccinated
children and hospitalized nine of them
look at that ratio 75 percent
hospitalization
we often forget how serious measles is
particularly in kids because vaccination
is so effective and this leads to some
parents saying whoever heard of a kid
getting measles it doesn't sound like
it's likely and it certainly doesn't
sound serious that's because of vaccines
we have a report now from
um NBC4 about how vaccine hesitancy that
has sort of spilled over from covet
vaccines into other vaccines is causing
exactly this problem take a listen to
this hey there everybody U.S childhood
vaccinations have dipped again this year
a new report from the CDC suggest what
started as a concern about the covid-19
vaccine especially in younger people is
now carrying over into other shots too
including polio diphtheria and measles
it's likely one of the reasons cluster
outbreaks of diseases such as measles
are on the rise CDC reports show last
year it was in the Twin Cities Minnesota
area currently it's in and around
Columbus Ohio in the Columbus outbreak
there are over 85 cases and can be
counting that was compared to last
week's data but over 30 of those kids
were hospitalized and most of those
cases were in unvaccinated children yeah
Dr Judy's work is a pediatrician who
told me this new report shows overall
those receiving vaccines required by
Most states is now at about 93 percent
it was at 95 percent just two years ago
before the pandemic now that 93 and 95
percent number is actually critically
important the herd immune measles is so
contagious that the herd immunity
threshold to prevent outbreaks is
considered to be 95 percent that has
dropped to 93 percent when it comes to
Children entering kindergarten with with
the required immunizations 93 when you
were below you know people think oh this
is some vague thing it's just numbers no
it has real world consequences when you
go below that herd immunity threshold
for some diseases you will start to see
outbreaks and that is exactly what is
going on and this was the fear that the
coveted anti-vaxxers who first entered
anti-vaxxerism with the covet vaccine
would bleed over into more General
opposition to child vaccinations because
the general environment starts to become
one of vaccine hesitancy and if you get
enough people in a community that are
skeptical or opposed to vaccines it can
make others in the community more likely
to say well if these three families
aren't doing it maybe I shouldn't do it
either if the health care providers if
the public health officials
aren't well prepared to deal with the
vaccine hesitancy they are going to be
under-resourced and not able to keep
those vaccine rates up and I've spoken
to a number of Pediatricians I know
friends of mine who say I get more
people than ever even in Liberal areas
people coming to me and saying you know
does my child really need all these
vaccines some of these things don't
really seem super serious or they don't
seem super common or likely that my
child would get
and the pediatricians have to explain
well that's because of the success and
effectiveness of many of these vaccines
this is a separate conversation from the
covet vaccine and unfortunately what we
expected to see happen is indeed
happening as we see
in these reports uh what we'll turn it
around I quite frankly don't know it's
pretty horrifying to be totally honest
I've had such trouble finding a great
razor where I am not cutting myself or
getting those Nicks on my skin which are
so common with the cheap disposable
razors you have to meet our sponsor
Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below